when I started my first gyms I was
making a few million dollars in Revenue
per year not a lot of profit but a few
million dollars in Revenue per year I
had a lot of different friends of mine
who were at the same level and obsessing
about different tax hacks and Tax
Strategies and all this stuff and for me
it always felt kind of silly because I'm
not making enough money anyways this is
going to matter I always took the
approach of I want to spend as little
time as possible trying to optimize for
this stuff and instead focus on what I
believe the thing that mattered most
which was getting better attaining more
skills reinvesting most of the capital I
had as an expense into education so I
didn't have a huge taxable income
because I was putting everything back
into learning new stuff getting into
communities getting workshops getting
skills getting tutoring so that I could
learn how to do things better and
ultimately make more money over the Long
Haul rather than trying to save 20 today